the next Awards will be presented by two
of our favorite people a beautiful and
talented lady who has come out here all
the way from her home in New York and a
popular and versatile gentleman who has
come out here all the way from his home
in Hollywood she flew up by TWA and
arrived this afternoon he came on the
freeway and is just pulling into the
parking lot miss Polly Bergen and mr.
Richard Widmark
we're here to present the award for the
best achievements in special effects
during the past year you see special
effects of the magic that make movies
the world's greatest entertainment the
seemingly impossible things that writers
dream up are put on the screen by the
Wizards of our special effects
departments volcanoes erupting dinosaurs
coming to life
automobiles flying through the air
whatever the mind can imagine the
effects man can bring him to be and
those nominated for the award this year
are AJ omen visual effects for the last
voyage Gene Warren and Tim Parr visual
effects for the time machine
Holly the winner thank you and the
winner is the time machine
wait a minute it's an honor to share
this with our associate watch-chain I'd
also like to share this honor with the
real master of special effects the
producer of time machine George pal